hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 20 video so many
awesome flashbacks we have to talk about
and there's a couple other things that
they tease that are gonna be happening
next week as well as the finale so I'll
try to address those too if you're
wondering why the plot seems like it's
starting to move faster and faster it's
because there's only 23 episodes this
season so next week will kind of be like
the beginning of the end just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet starting with top five
moments number five team flash learns
all about the Gideon computer Barry
learns that he creates the Gideon
computer which is why it Oh basil and
learns all about his future like they
actually read the future newspaper and
they learned that the reverse flashes
name is eobard thawne I was kind of
wondering how that was gonna happen like
they knew the name the reverse flash in
Harrison wells but they didn't know that
he was a Bart Thawne they don't know
anything about the future until now if
you didn't recognize the voice it's
Morena Baccarin from gotham she's also
gonna be in the Deadpool movie too she's
all over the place we actually see her
go into human computer form we've seen
her as a floaty head before and we've
seen her on the reverse flashes wrist
but now it's like I'm much more full-on
shot I'm actually kind of curious as to
why they did it this way why she wasn't
just a floaty head but this is not the
last we've seen of the Gideon computer
all the computer screens were playing
the CCTV footage that the reverse-flash
had been capturing it's possible that he
took the AI with him whenever he left we
also got that awesome Back to the Future
joke whereby Cisco is like hey look at
that flash suit that you're wearing that
looks way cooler than this wait wait a
minute do we get the idea because we
looked at this that will actually be
what the flash suit looks like they'll
eventually do the classic logo but I
don't know if that's gonna be season 2
or if we'll see that before the finale
other really important things learned
the reverse-flash
went back in time to kill Barry and then
killed Nora Allen because he was angry
that probably has something to do with
adult Barry going back in time to try
and stop the reverse flash like future
Barry prevents the death of young Barry
so as a consolation the reverse flash
kills Nour Allen will continue to go
back to that moment in time so we'll get
more perspective on it as we build
towards the finale I know every was
asking about green arrow Hawkgirl that
you know the stuff that it actually said
in the future newspaper this could be
something that they deliver in the form
of a promo for the spin-off series just
save it in your bookmarks the flash is
pretty good about delivering on promises
it makes so they said Hawkgirl we know
she's gonna be in the spinoff this is
probably gonna connect that somehow
moving on to number four Eddie wants to
propose to Iris it doesn't take a
genetically enhanced gorilla to figure
out that there's no way this is going
down the show keeps finding ways to
drive wedges between Iris and Eddie and
finding other ways to push Barry and
iris together as much as it's okay for
TV shows to mess with the timeline and
play around with can a little bit
eventually we will get to like that
west-allen relationship for those of you
they're big fans of that if you don't
care about the relationships on the show
you know don't worry they're gonna use
this relationship as a point of
falling-out between Eddie and Barry
remember the reverse-flash said that
Eddie is his insurance policy iris is
probably gonna be at the Nexus of that
and while this is going on
iris figures out that Barry is the flash
moving that's number three the reverse
flash reveals to Eddie that he is his
descendant
I like how Eddie for a moment thought
that it might have been about him the
whole time when he said that Eddie is
his insurance policy he's just talking
about you know a future you Bart on
being born so if he dies as a result of
what happens in the finale then a future
eobard thawne will still be born and he
can do it again as you noticed a bar
thought you know throws the ring to the
side all he needs for that insurance
policy to pay out so to speak is for
Eddie to do what he did originally Eddie
and iris only started their relationship
because Barry went into the coma because
he barred Thawne jump started the
process of him becoming the flash in the
original timeline the reason the Barry
and iris are married in 2024 is because
he never went into a coma so their
relationship developed much much quicker
the accident in the coma took things in
a different direction which is where you
get to Eddie and iris so eobard thawne
will probably do some things to double
down on that insurance policy you know
making sure that Eddie does not end up
with iris one easy way to do that would
be to kill her moving that's number two
Cisco goes into a waking dream to find
out what happened in the alternate
timeline this is a bit of a twist
everybody when we saw this in the
trailer earlier thought that it might be
part of like some Cisco vibe technology
turns out it's all about waking dreams
the
cast his t's that we might see killer
frost caitlin snow before we see cisco
vibe but when we do eventually see cisco
vibe I think it'll be like a tech based
v you won't be like a metahuman so don't
worry we'll get there eventually but
essentially we visited the alternate
timeline twice there was the first time
in the wakingdream
and then again when they tried to
recreate it in real life so both times
the speeches that Harrison wells gives
are just like a little bit different the
second time was mostly because he was
Hannibal Bates it wasn't really Harrison
wells and finally my number one WTF
moment
Harrison wells calls their bluff and
ends up trapping them when they tried to
trap him if you're a little confused
with Barry's line at the end we thought
we were creating a trap for him but he
was trapping us the whole time
what that was referring to wasn't just
specifically what happened in this
episode it was referring to the series
of events since the particle accelerator
explosion Wells has been trying to
maneuver Barry into a position where he
can tap into his Speed Force so he can
go back to the future that's the trap so
team flash is still like inside the trap
we probably won't see him spring that
trap until the finale that's like you
know the big WTF finale moment so like
each time Barry unlocks the new ability
like he did in this episode you know
spinning his arms to create a vacuum he
gets a little bit more powerful and a
little bit closer to where the
reverse-flash needs him to be the comics
tell like a slightly different story
they they tell more of like a a positive
negative charge to the Speed Force
whereby any time the flash taps into the
Speed Force he makes the reverse flash
more powerful like he charges the
negative Speed Force which is what the
reverse flash taps into I haven't seen
any evidence that the show is gonna get
really granular with with how they
describe the Speed Force in terms of
like positive negative charge I think
what they'll do is they'll simplify it
and they'll just have the reverse flash
try to siphon off the Speed Force from
Barry once he gets powerful enough the
Hannibal Bates twist was really good
especially the reverse flash calling
them and saying you know you're smart
but you're not that smart we will have a
confrontation very very soon
that's probably referring to what this
moment is right here this image
firestorm Rachael Mel in the flash
versus the reverse flash there was that
recent trailer they posted where they
said the particle accelerator is charged
Cisco has that line because Cisco had
the line it might be team flash trying
to use the particle accelerator to take
down the reverse flash
the only surefire way for team flash to
neutralize the reverse-flash is to take
away his speed force that's actually
something they addressed it in the Wally
West era the flash comics he was able to
transfer Speed Force so we might see a
version of that this season here's my
big question for you guys how do you
think that the reverse flash is going to
try and manipulate Eddie Thawne moving
into the finale Eddie has a lot of
potential to become a villain in a
future season right now he's the Flash's
best friend but hunter zolomon was Wally
West's best friend and even though I
like the eobard thawne reverse-flash way
more Eddie could totally become another
version of the reverse-flash there were
a couple really big Easter eggs that I
haven't mentioned yet already when
eobard thawne is talking about cops in a
hundred years being just as useless as
they are now he was actually talking
about his brother if you read the road
to flashpoint comic book it tells the
story of eobard thawne it tells what
happened to him as a child how he became
the reverse-flash the first time at a
certain point he started to do some
illegal research his brother who had
become a police officer tried to stop
him a future version of eobard thawne
who had already become the reverse-flash
went back in time and eliminated his
brother from the timestream so that his
brother never existed in the first place
to stop him eobard thawne's one of those
characters in the comics that doesn't
hesitate to edit his own timeline for
his own benefit Barry here puts captain
colds glasses on from the comics this is
just what they look like in the comics
and at the end of the episode when Barry
says I couldn't have done this without
you and Harrison wells says I feel the
same about you he's obviously talking
about you know Barry becoming the flash
creating the Speed Force
he's like the point of origin of the
Speed Force many many years in the
future hey Bart Thawne uncovers a time
capsule with Barry Allen's flash suit
and uses it to reverse engineer flash
powers which is why he called himself
the reverse flash he literally reverse
engineered the flash there was a whole
bunch of Cisco movie Easter eggs you
know Kalima Temple of Doom the Back to
the Future Polaroid with Marty
disappearing based on how they altered
the timeline but if you saw any others
just write them below in the comments
next week is a really big episode it's
called Grodd lives gonna be a big Grodd
episode obviously they released these
images so you kind of see what Grodd
looks like in better lighting it's a
nice mirror image of this panel of the
flash Grodd is one of those really
awesome
they probably won't be able to use a
whole bunch of just because he's kind of
expensive to do in CG tomorrow a new
arrow video coming after the episode
airs be sure to subscribe to get it
I'm still wondering what team arrow is
gonna do to get Oliver out of the League
of Assassins or if it's gonna be his
decision while you guys wait for all
that stuff to post in case you haven't
seen it I posted a Gotham video from
last night you can click here to watch
it and you can click here for all my
other flash and arrow videos thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you